[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker never quit on any of his
teams
some of his teams ask him to quit the
former nfl player now the host of the
ross tucker football
podcast also the uh analyst for uh
westwood one kind enough to join us
how are you ross dan i'm
fantastic except i'm on chat row right
now
at dan patrick.com and i can't figure
out how to change my
avatar i got to get this beautiful
meathead james van der beek picture on
there so i'm just a uh
i'm like the people on twitter i hate
right now i'm a nameless faceless guy
you do look like uh a bigger james van
der beek
i i see it like um a thicker
beefier james van der beek yeah i've
always gotten that one
and putty from seinfeld those are the
two i've gotten a million
times the thing is like i don't think
either one of those guys looked like
each other
i i don't get the meathead vanderbeek
one i kind of get the putty one he's a
big guy go devils
gotta support the team i never really
understood the van der beek one but
enough people say it
and uh yeah i don't know how we one day
you were out and i was filling in they
call me meathead vanderbeek
well fritzy looks like paulie from rocky
which i hate but he does
look like paulie from rocky
hidden rocco you know what i never heard
that before
and fritzi i i kind of see you a little
bit thank you
thanks a lot i can't remember what i
can't remember what movie it was
but what is up with you taking all of
rocky's hard-earned money
i mean he's in there punching people
getting punched
and then you spend and blow all his
money fritz terrible
was that rocky iv that you did then i
did in the soviet union there yeah they
think that was the one that was pocketed
um all right your reaction to j.j watt
going to arizona's
what what uh
uh initial reaction dan was surprised
because it hadn't been one of the teams
that had been reported right you heard a
lot about the bills the browns
certainly the packers it felt like the
arizona cardinals kind of came out of
nowhere
uh you know look i'll be honest dan i
think he went to the place that offered
him the most
money and i've got no problem with that
whatsoever
you know i think a lot of times people
say he should have gone here for a ring
or should have gone there for a ring
like look at look at the vegas odds okay
it's really
hard to win a ring so
would the packers have a better chance
in the cardinals yeah
would the buffalo bills have a better
chance in the cardinals probably
but the packers haven't been in super
bowl in 10 years
so okay he goes there marginally better
chance to go to super bowl or he goes to
buffalo bill they haven't been in the
super bowl
in almost 30 years whatever it is
i think the only thing you know for sure
dan
is the money that you're going to get
from that contract and i know fans don't
want to hear this
and i know all of your listeners want
guys to just go
or they think they have a best chance to
win a ring is it
likely in arizona probably not
but this is his last big bite at the
apple
they gave him the most guaranteed money
it sounds like
by far i don't blame him one bit
they don't have as good a chance with a
super bowl some of these other teams but
they do have a chance they're not a
terrible team
and he gets the guaranteed money he was
looking for i don't blame him
i think this just comes down to
lifestyle for j.j watt and i have no
problem with that i know we want guys to
chase the ring
until they chase the ring and then we
criticize you for chasing the ring
i think j.j want probably looked at this
and said
it's a good team maybe not a great team
i can be a leader there
and uh you know his wife is from utah
maybe this is just comes down to
something simple of
you know the money was important but
lifestyle as well
uh if you if you've been to scottsdale
this time of the year
it's a wonderful place to live and maybe
that's all this was
all right a couple other things here i
mentioned first hour i have the perfect
landing spot for alex smith
washington football team doesn't want
him anymore he's 36 years of age
and do you want to know what my pick is
i have a guess okay i was not listening
i'm gonna guest chicago bears
jacksonville jaguars oh
interesting reunited with urban meyer at
age 36
you're going to be drafting trevor
lawrence you're able to sort of be that
liaison
backup quarterback offensive coordinator
assistant head coach
whatever it is and and not a lot of
pressure there
maybe you start out as the starter as
trevor lawrence gets acclimated there
but i thought alex smith
on that roster made a whole lot of sense
for uh
for uh urban meyer yeah it's the first
time i've heard that dan
uh i like it what i really like the most
about it
is for trevor lawrence i mean alex smith
is an awesome guy consummate
professional
if you listen to patrick mahomes talk
about alex smith
and what alex did for mahomes that first
year
patrick mahomes gives alex smith a ton
of credit so
from jacksonville's perspective it
absolutely makes sense especially with
trevor
having this torn labrum shoulder surgery
maybe you don't want him out there
week one maybe he needs a couple weeks
the thing i don't like about it dan
i i don't think alex wants to really be
a backup i don't want to put words in
his mouth but
i think alex wants to play him he's made
a ton of money he may not have a choice
he may not have a choice though
i think you're right i don't think i
think it'd be tough
for any team right now to say alex smith
is our guy you know the one place right
now
is that maybe matt nagy who worked with
him in kansas city thinks
yeah i can win 10 games with alex he'll
be better than trubisky or foles would
be
but you know that injury he suffered dan
is just so tricky
there's a reason why he had calf issues
at the end of the season
there's a reason why he couldn't play in
the playoff game
i don't think any team is going to hitch
their wagon alex smith i think you're
right
and i think jacksonville probably does
end up becoming maybe his best spot
we haven't had yawn since the uh russell
wilson story blew up
and the fact that his agent publicly
says to adam schefter hey if we want to
stay but if we get traded here's the
four teams here
to me that felt like that's that's the
end
that that's you can't be one foot in and
one foot out you can't be sort of
pregnant
and it feels like hey we want to stay
but
what do you think happens with russell
wilson eventually
yeah so two two separate and distinct
things here in my mind number one
you know for him to go on with you and
say the things that he said
i was really surprised i've always been
a big russell wilson fan big russell
wilson supporter
but to say that he's tired of getting
hit so much
you know hey russell you kind of have
the ball in your hand
you kind of control that how about
throwing the ball away
how about getting rid of the ball sooner
you know i will just tell you as a
former offensive lineman
i took offense to that right like that
was like publicly calling out
his offensive line and to some extent in
my mind publicly calling himself out
what happened to that personal
accountability personal responsibility
you don't see tom brady say i'm sick of
getting hit too much or drew brees
they get rid of the ball so that
bothered me and then this whole thing of
he doesn't want to go somewhere else but
if he does
these are the team what does that even
mean he doesn't want to go somewhere
else
but if he does these are the teams i
don't know
i don't know dan if he really wants to
leave
or if he's figured out that the best way
to have everybody talking about you is
to leak that you want to go somewhere
else and to even start to leak
specifically i mean
people in chicago are going crazy
there's i saw some guy tweet
that russell wilson saying he wanted to
go to the bears
is the third best quarterback in bear's
history just russell wilson
saying he wanted to go to the bears i
mean that was
that was why would he want to go there
why like
why would you want to go to the bears
that doesn't make sense
that was paulie who tweeted that ross
it was paulie said it's the third
greatest moment for a
potential bears quarterback that russ
just mentioned the bears on his uh
wish list of four you just think he
wants to be talked about
and that's why they're leaking all of
this
there are people that believe that
russell wilson
sort of fancies himself dan as as like
the football magic johnson
over the next 10 20 years of his life
and wants to have that type of
business impact he is really into
investing
he's really into doing deals where he
gets equity
and he's got a lot of people that he
talks to it's my understanding
and i think that part of it might be i
don't think it's all of it
i think there is some frustration that
they haven't been able to get back to
the super bowl
but let's just say this i i think he has
realized
that his name being in the news is not a
negative
for all of the other things he wants to
accomplish off the field
we're talking to ross tucker former nfl
player and a host of the ross tucker
football podcast also
ross's birthday today happy birthday
ross thank you i am
twice the legal drinking limit so i will
have some
daddy sodas tonight i will say this dan
i
i don't like birthdays anymore i i i'm
at the age where i no longer like i'm
like 42. that
i i don't like birthdays my wife thinks
i'm weird it's like well it's better
than the alternative but i don't
i'm not loving birthdays anymore i think
up until like 35 i still liked my
birthday
now i'm like no we don't need to talk
about it and maybe that means i'm a
weirdo now i don't know i
i'm not loving it do you did you get
well
no you weren't playing in february or
march so you wouldn't get gifts from
your teammates when when you played
right no but um you know we obviously
got gifts
at around christmas time there were some
guys that were better than others
dan look drew bledsoe the one year he
got us
two plane tickets anywhere you wanted to
go so that's where my wife and i went on
our honeymoon to hawaii
thanks to bledsoe's plane tickets the
next year he gave us
a motorola droid razor when that was
like the coolest phone
and he paid the bill unlimited minutes
for like three years
until his mom called me and was like hi
ross this is barbara bledsoe
um drew's mom the gift is over now
meanwhile uh dan there was emmett smith
who my second year i started the last
seven games for emmett
he gave us uh signed emmett smith
uh all-time leading rusher book signed
emmett smith jersey
and a signed bottle of emmett smith
all-time leading rusher wine
a wine bottle that he signed it was
amazing
so you were probably mad when brady took
over for drew bledsoe because that meant
you were not getting any great gifts
well
so i the funny thing is you really only
get the gift if you're a starter
so i only got the gift three years my
second year my third year and my fourth
year
my rookie year i i didn't get one of the
gifts from tony banks or whoever it was
in washington
when i was in new england i didn't get a
gift from anybody
um so yeah you really only get the gift
if you're a starter
but it is pretty sweet i've seen some of
the gifts these guys get now they're
unbelievable they get like four-wheelers
and stuff that would have been amazing
how many how many plays did you play
with brady
zero i started in enter
no in all sincerity i only played so the
patriots picked me up
midway through the 05 year i only played
the fourth quarter of the dolphins game
week 17 when uh matt castle came in and
doug flutie did the dropkick
and i played on special teams against
the broncos you know that's one of my
claim to fames dan
i only ever played in one playoff game
and it was the first playoff game that
brady ever lost
[Laughter]
brady was like 10-0 in the playoffs
until i got in
and then uh did brady know your name
wrong what say it again did brady know
your name
absolutely okay yeah because i think he
he comes every time he gets signed the
first thing he does come up to you and
he's like
shakes your hand hi ross i'm tom nice to
meet you like hi tom i know who you are
and then uh he i was the center a lot in
practice
so he would come in the huddle and be
like all right ross you and me
great snap first like he takes it real
real
seriously so he definitely uh definitely
knew who i was and then 06
i got traded to cleveland so i never
actually was
in a regular season game with tom brady
give me that
impersonation of brady again in the
huddle
so before he calls the play he looks at
me and dan this is like
spring otas he's already won three super
bowls
he's like all right ross you and me
great snap first grace at first
and then i'm like 26 27 i've started 25
games
and i look at him i'm like all right man
all right but in my head i'm like okay
tom
okay i mean dude this is
this this i i gotta say this dan he
lives his life
differently than anybody else so i
played 18 years of football
i was a lineman most the time the
quarterback center exchange
is so mundane it's so like you take a
ball
you hit your butt crack with it the
quarterback's top hand is there
boom quarterback's like uh whatever i
never played with a quarterback
that cared nearly as much about that
snap as brady and this is practice but
like
in his psychopath head he wanted that
like that smack when he hit the top hand
because that meant it was a perfect snap
he could look at the defense a little
sooner so like
think about anything in life okay
and you just you're just doing something
to do it brady doesn't look at
anything like that brady looks at every
single thing in his life
as a chance to get just a little bit
better at it
and try to perfect that's why he is who
he is you're the best
hey happy birthday ross i hope you don't
get any gifts today
[Laughter]
thank you dan see you guys i'll be back
on chat row right now shout out chat row
and back row
all right that's uh ross tucker former
nfl player and uh host of the ross
tucker football podcast
and uh an analyst for westwood one